new rules to make it easier for online  music stores to stream music across  Europe's borders are being adopted by EU  ministers meeting in Brussels under the  Greek presidency the laws aimed to  encourage the creation of EU wide online  music services for consumers and ensure  that the rights of artists are better  protected and their royalties paid more  quickly instead of having to obtain  copyright licenses in every EU country  online providers will be able to get  them from management organizations  operating across borders on behalf of  the artists the rules will apply to  online retailers like Apple and Amazon  but also to streaming services such as  Spotify and the system is likely to  encourage new providers to set up shop  the results should mean more and better  online music services for consumers and  cheaper prices the measures were  approved by the European Parliament in  early February countries will have two  years to incorporate them international  law